the future of Batman is exciting but
slightly complicated
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
now the DC isn't exactly my favorite
studio for making superhero movies
Marvel kicked their ass and even though
Marvel aren't doing very well at the
moment but generally Marvel kick their
ass every single time
but I do love the character of Batman he
might actually be my favorite superhero
and when Warner Brothers do a Batman
movie well oh they're brilliant
Warner Brothers Discovery Inc has a new
CEO and David zazlaf and he has been
actually taking an ax to a lot of
projects he doesn't like and trying to
steer the Behemoth that is Warner
Brothers in a slightly different
direction he wants to completely rework
what's been going on with the DC now it
does seem that David zaslav is
instructing HBO and DC to go on a
slightly different Direction with the DC
Universe but they do seem to be being
really careful not to throw out the baby
with the bathwater news that Henry
Cavill is coming back as Superman has
been genuinely cheered by fans it's
something we want to see we're going to
be looking forward to Aquaman 2. Black
Adam has already shown that actually we
still have an appetite for the DC and we
still want to see these characters but
we do want to see them in slightly
better movies
Wonder Woman 1984.
God's sake
but we still want to see Wonder Woman we
just again want to see her in better
movies so what I'm being told is that
the plan for the DC new universe is that
they are going to forget about what
hasn't worked but they're going to focus
on what has so what does that mean for
Batman the first thing it means Ben
Affleck is going to be returning his
Batman but he's not going to be the only
Batman on our screens let's talk about
Ben first though it has been confirmed
by Janessa Momoa that he is returning at
least in a small part for Aquaman 2.
there have been rumors that he has
signed on with Warner Brothers for a
multi-movie deal now I can confirm that
apparently that is not necessarily true
he has agreed to come on um for certain
cameos but there are conversations about
a standalone Batman movie within this
universe with the Aquaman Shazam Etc
Universe with Ben Affleck but that has
not been signed and has not been finally
agreed Ben Affleck has been having
conversations
he has a very distinct idea where he
would like the Batman character to go
that is not the way Zack Snyder took the
character is the main reason why Ben
Affleck tried very hard to get away from
the character because of the way it was
handled particularly in Justice League
he wants a far more gritty more
realistic Batman character in the future
now so what you like about Ben Affleck
as an actor you cannot argue with his
intelligence he is a very intelligent
actor so for me I'm hoping that these
conversations continue and that they do
convince him to return his Batman
because I actually quite liked him but
just like everything else in the DC I
want a really good actor in a really
good character in a much better movie if
you haven't subscribed already please do
and like and share the video wherever
the hell you want also if you enjoy the
content and you want to support the
Channel please hit the join button also
we have our sister Channel Sidetrack
size where we do lots of little best
bits from the lives and lots of other
fun silly little videos so please go and
subscribe to science but this is not the
only Batman we're getting because
obviously we're getting Robert Pattinson
returning now we're going to be getting
the Batman 2. we're also going to be
getting a spin-off TV series in the
penguin Colin Farrell why didn't they
just get a fat guy to do that why did
they get Colin Farrell and then put him
under someone's makeup you can't even
tell it's Colin Farrell I don't get that
and then if you're Colin Farrell why do
you agree to do a TV series when you're
gonna have to be wearing that main Cup
every day for like six months there must
be paying him a crapload of money
now I don't know where they're going
that TV series but actually HBO and Max
have done pretty well
um in doing these little spin-off TV
series
um I personally hated Suicide Squad I
thought it was awful but I loved
Peacemaker I thought it was great I
loved where they took the character
um if they can do that again with
something like the Penguin and do
something a little bit different that's
still within that Universe I'll applaud
it but there are apparently two other
big Batman projects being considered
sadly yesterday we heard the news that
the voice of Batman for me Kevin Conroy
passed away
now I remember Batman the Animated
Series really really well when I was a
kid it was it really impacted me because
of the sheer quality of the cartoon now
we're quite used to better quality
cartoons nowadays things like the Clone
Wars of Star Wars and even lower deck
static and things like that but back
then
this was a Quantum Leap it was so much
better than everything else they were
like small animated movies rather than
just the cartoons we were used to on a
Saturday morning I am the Knight
I am Batman and one of the really big
things that impacted me was Kevin
Conroy's portrayal of Batman his voice
is Batman if you were a kid back in the
90s and early 2000s then chances are you
were probably watching the animated
series about the Batman
behind every great Animated Hero is a
great voice actor and for me that actor
is Kevin Conroy
how was that that was good Kevin keep
going okay
he will be sorely missed and
any any new animated Batman series will
really miss Kevin's voice but related to
the Batman animated series they Then
followed that up with Batman Beyond
Kevin again did the voice for Batman now
there are conversations about that
series returning but not in an animated
version in a live action series now
apparently what I'm being told by my
source at Warner Brothers is that that
would be a very grown-up very Ultra
violent series that would be sort of
like a punk sci-fi type of thing quite
similarly actually to the original
cartoon that we would see Gotham in the
future we're going to see flying cars
and everything else it'll feel a bit
like Blade Runner is the kind of thing
they're aiming for apparently we will
see an elderly Batman taking on a new
Squire somebody takes on the mantle of
Batman
the thing I'm quite excited about this
as well is that we'll basically get to
see this strip Back to Basics we're
going to see a Batman that doesn't
really know what he's doing so the
villains he'll just be taken on the
focus and stuff at first but then he
will obviously progress and start taking
on more Super villainy types we're also
going to get to see some really cool
Technologies some very cool sci-fi in
with a superhero series and if Warner
Brothers have got any sense at all
they've got the perfect man to take on
the role of the elderly Batman
Michael Keaton now we've already seen
him in the CW so he's obviously shown
that this is a character he will more
than happily come back to if they did a
proper series and Michael Keaton took on
the role as a geriatric Batman ugh
I I I dare you not to watch it this
could actually be an amazing project and
I really hope it's more than just talk
there is though however a another Batman
project that will be an animated movie
now Warner Brothers animation have been
making these Batman movies for quite a
long time there's Batman Samurai and
there's there's loads of others um I'm
pretty sure there was one like set in
like 1888 London like Batman Sherlock
Holmes but I might be imagining that but
apparently this will be more of an
alternative Batman they're looking at
more like what Spider-Man did with into
the spider-verse or the what if series
now apparently James Gunn is really
interested in this project and it's
something he would very much be
interested in watching over I think
Warner Brothers animation has got a
really good history of this and if they
do something and they actually put a bit
of effort into it and it's not just
something they do as a throwaway project
it could be absolutely amazing
but this does of course mean we're going
to have at least
four different Batmans on our screens in
different time frames and different
universes
so we've got the Batman with Mike Robert
Patterson
Batman with Ben Affleck in a completely
different Universe Batman Beyond Batman
that I think could actually be sort of
like if it is Michael Keaton it could
almost be an extension of the now
canceled and defunct CW Batman series
and the Flash sort of thing
um and we're gonna have an at least one
animated project
so get ready to be slightly confused but
having some really great Batman
characters knocking around and as I say
I'm very excited about it because he is
by far the coolest of all the
superheroes but guys tell me what you
think
is this something you're interested by
is Batman Beyond a cartoon you remember
even if not I strongly suggest you go
back and have a look because it was
fantastic please get in the comments and
tell me exactly what you think if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and if you enjoy the
content and you want to support the
channel become a fully fledged side
Trekker and hit the join button also
don't forget to subscribe to Sidetrack
sides as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next time
[Music]